so our next
speaker has uh he was one of the first
people ever to post on the
rstan online helpless User Group
list please and if you don't know rstan
you should all know ran it's great for
basing computations so please welcome
another David come on down David all
right uh can you'all hear me fantastic
all right uh yeah okay I I've had
trouble with mics in the past uh so all
right uh hey everyone I'm going to talk
about uh data science and politics
everybody loves politics uh
so oh I just need to do the the mouse
thing okay fantastic you want no no I
I'll survive I don't need a CLI uh
Simple Man Okay uh all right so first uh
who are we uh so I am one of the
co-founders of blue rose research uh
we're a roughly 35 person shop uh
founded by alumni the Obama campaign I
have like a big ball of text up there uh
but uh I'd say that uh our main thing is
that we uh were a data science F focused
firm trying to elect Democrats we work
with uh you know I'd say most of the
major Spenders in the Democratic party
we have over a hundred clients in uh
more than three countries uh and our big
thing uh is that we do very large uh
numbers of surveys uh in order to help
politician in order to test content and
help politicians figure out you know
what to say I'll go more into the
details but just to talk about some of
the highlights you know we've done
literally thousands of experiments on
millions of people we've helped allocate
hundreds of millions of dollars uh and
we've uh predicted uh We've you know
helped provide races AC predictions
across multiple cycles for nearly every
uh election in the in the country okay
so uh just what what do how do you
actually do uh data science why is data
science relevant uh for politics uh you
know I like to break things down in kind
of a boring unromantic way uh which is
that a lot of what political campaigns
try to do is answer the questions of uh
what do I say what's happening and how
do I actually spend my money how that uh
translates uh you know on a day-to-day
basis can take a lot of forms you know
uh when you're deciding what to say that
could mean what uh what AD should I put
in the air what talking point should I
feed to the Press you know what policies
should I base my campaign on and we try
to you know build tools to help people
answer those questions uh when it comes
to what's happening uh there's both how
is the world around us changing and uh
how is public opinion changing and
response to events and then there's also
mechanically okay I have $500 million
how do I spend it across Senate races in
order to maximize my expected Senate
seats and uh then when it comes to how
how to spend your money it turns out uh
you know buying ads which unfortunately
is what most of TV uh political
campaigns are very complicated um and so
just to talk a little bit about what the
you know what we actually do on a day
today basis I would say that big picture
we survey really large numbers of people
uh We join that information to a voter
file um generally political campaigns in
the US though not in other countries
have access to a big creepy uh voter
file of every person in the country and
uh and you know what elections they
voted in and various uh things like that
uh and then we uh score you know we fit
models on the survey data we score every
person in the country and then we you
know do a bunch of uh analysis on the
basis of that
um so you know why is this hard uh so
the first thing uh is that politics has
a lot of structure uh and you know what
that means in practice uh is that you
know what makes people choose uh who to
vote for uh is really a function of a
really complicated interplay of uh of
factors like religiosity educ ation uh
socieconomic
status uh and you know they're both the
relative weight of those things can
change over time it can change over
space uh there are some parts of the
country where much thing where some
where a lot these factors are more
important than others and the relative
importance can change dramatically uh in
response to world events and then you
know uh a lot of the things that we're
trying to measure or a lot of the things
that drive voter Behavior are things
that are psychometric quantities which
in some ways don't even exist um you
know I think the hardest thing about
this the central problem uh in our field
is that survey takers are just really
really weird um and I'll talk about this
more later um you know when I first
started uh working in this space a bit
over a decade ago something like one in
10 people would answer phone surveys
that number is uh now down to one and
200 or 300 um uh and so you know at this
point the sheer Act of answering a
survey is a political act uh I think my
favorite statistic about uh like if you
look at people who answer phone surveys
even among the people who say they
definitely will not vote something like
80% of those people vote um just because
you know we're talking you have to just
be incredibly interested in politics in
order to get people to answer these
things uh and they're also weirder in a
bunch of other ways you know it turns
out you know for example that uh Jewish
men are much more likely to answer phone
uh answer surveys than other groups
which is unsurprising to me personally
um uh you know but there's a whole host
of other things like that that make this
hard
um and then I think the other thing
that's hard is you know we fit all of
these models um but I think in a lot of
traditional business analytics uh you
know you're just trying to maximize you
know the Au of your model and you can
say well you know we could make
everything a lot more complicated but
then that would only increase the Au of
our models by like 01 so we're just
going to save the tech debt but what
sucks about what we do is you know we
have this very spatially autocorrelated
an error which is a fancy way of saying
that we roll all of our stuff up to make
decisions and so you you know if uh
there's a hypothetically a quirk in
southern western V in southern Western
Virginia where 70% of people are still
registered Democrats even though Biden
got 20% of the vote that's actually you
know true and West Virginia's third
congressional district if that that one
Edge case you know less than 0.1% of the
country lives there but if it gives you
a wrong forecast and you end up
overspending in a district by millions
of dollars that's really bad um and so
we have to end up making our models
quite a bit more complicated than the
other than we otherwise would be um and
then I think the other thing that sucks
uh you know just in the same vein is
that uh you know we really try to
measure two things um at our shop one is
changes in public opinion over time and
the other is changes in how people
change their mind in response to seeing
ads or arguments or content and both of
these things are incredibly small uh you
know this n the thing I like to say
about this is that in 2012 Barack Obama
got about 52% of the vote and in 2016
Hillary Clinton got 51 1% of the
two-party vote so that's a 0.9% change
over four years um but you know uh it
made a big difference uh so measuring
small effects is is in our case is
important which is a shame because
measuring small effects is hard um all
right so how we actually deal with this
don't worry I'm not going to actually
read all of these all these things up
here but uh if folks want to um the
first thing is that we just survey
really large numbers of people um we did
something like 15 million uh interviews
in the 2022 cycle and we're on track to
do uh substantially more now uh I think
that we are one of the largest
purchasers by volume of online survey
data in the world which um I guess is
cool um but that as I think any
statistician could tell you that you
know it's that you can't actually solve
all your problems by just surveying
really large numbers of people that's
not a solution to bias and so really big
thing uh is that we work with a really
uh uh we work with a lot of different
panels to collect information from
people who normally don't take surveys
my favorite example is one of our
biggest panels the way they get people
is people are playing Candy Crush they
run out of lives and then it's like oh
would you like to take a survey in order
to go uh and uh you know that does get
to this trade-off which I haven't seen
too many survey people talk about which
is people always talk about you know
data quality uh in surveys getting high
quality survey takers and the problem
that we found is that all of the really
high quality panels um are filled with
people who are really weird um uh and so
all of the shittier panels you know kind
of filled with the people who aren't
paying attention those people are a lot
more normal um but then the data is less
reliable and so that creates a lot of
hard tradeoffs um you know the other
thing we do is that we just use a lot
more data you know we join to a lot more
things we have things like uh
administrative data we uh you know
traditional surveys only control for
things like age and race and gender and
we control for literally dozens of
different attitudinal characteristics
because our whole philosophy is given
that survey takers are weird our really
only hope out is to just measure exactly
how weird they are so that we can try to
adjust for that um you know the other
thing I'll say just to talk a little bit
um is and I mean I don't think too many
people here work on surveys but uh we
don't use any survey weights um you know
I I think I remember reading as a
teenager you know Andrew gelman's um
would always say you know you shouldn't
use weights you should just put
everything into this one big model and I
always compare that to you know when
you're young you uh you read The
Communist Manifesto and you're like oh
my God this is beautiful this is so
exciting and then you spend the next 10
years of your life trudging through D
capital and you're like ah God this
section it's a lot harder than I thought
it would be um uh but we've really tried
to make the dream you know Andrew
Gilman's dream of fitting big
multi-level models um work and uh I
think we've made some progress um and
then you know the other big thing and I
think that there's probably some broader
um you know some broader Insight Beyond
politics and surveys is that we do
really extensive back testing and QC on
all of our stuff you know every single
time we make any change to you know our
at this point very complicated process
we see how it will how it would have
affected all of our forecasts and you
know hundreds of past races that we've
pulled uh and you know we end up finding
that lots of seemingly minor changes
that we do go back and break everything
um and so it's a good uh it's a good
thing to go and do that um so now I'm
going to go through some graphs which is
fun uh so uh because the whole thing is
because we have this uh this whole this
you know uh whole workflow that allows
us to score individual people we can end
up answering a lot of questions about
politics that would be pretty hard so
wise so this is an example where what
we're showing you know in every state
generally speaking elections are
different from year to year and so you
know one example uh is that uh Democrats
did worse in Florida in uh in 2022 than
they did in 2020 um even and you know
even then 2020 was a fairly bad uh year
but it got worse and so it's a natural
question that people argue about which
is like how much of that was changes in
who voted versus uh people actually
changing their mind and in uh Florida
you know we could see these two bars it
was a roughly even split of both but it
turns out that you know what was what
really varied a lot by state you know
for example in Pennsylvan uh in
Pennsylvania turnout was actually
somewhat worse for Democrats but people
just really loved John betterman and he
just was in and that's and he was able
to overcome that uh and so this is the
kind of thing that normally would be
very hard to answer but you know with
modeling you can go and do that um you
know this is uh some more plots this is
just showing a reason why surveys
surveying has gotten a lot harder uh
basically uh one of the biggest drivers
of uh answer of answering surveys is you
know this latent socio economic status
um people generally speaking who are
more educated really like taking surveys
it's kind of a form of self-expression
for them and uh what the reason why uh
you know that's now a problem is that in
the past eight years or I guess in the
past 10 years there's been a really big
realignment on education lines where uh
people who are very educated have become
a lot more liberal and people who are
less educated have become a lot more
conservative uh and you know you could
see that with these you know County
Scatter Plots and so then you could say
all right well great let's just adjust
for Education um but it turns out that
actually uh education is just symbolic
of a whole host of differences that
represent socioeconomic status this is
this is showing social trust um if you
ask people do you believe that people
can generally be trusted uh it turns out
70% of people say no uh which is fun uh
and probably somewhat concerning uh but
what you could also see from a
measurement perspective is like in 2016
you know the the college whites well the
college whites who answered uh that they
trust the people around them or the
non-oled whites that did swung toward
Clinton the ones that didn't swung
toward Trump and this is this was a big
problem because in 2016 the uh the
non-oled whites who trusted the people
around them were the only people who
answered phone surveys which is uh why
the polls were wrong in
2016 um just to go through some some
more graphs um just to get it uh
politics being complicated this is just
showing uh you know two-way uh you know
support for the presidential candidate
in 2016 by race attitudes toward the
Bible and education uh and then also
showing ideology and so you can see a
bunch of things here that are uh you
know uh that are interesting the
non-additivity of uh of these things you
know the first is uh generally speaking
uh being more religious uh really
corresponds with being more Republican
among white people but among
African-Americans religious
African-Americans are actually somewhat
uh more uh more democratic than less SEC
uh less religious ones and you know the
reason for that is a complicated
interplay of History uh or another thing
that's interesting is you know when
people talk about partisanship and
ideology they kind of use them as
synonyms for each other but it turn you
know this just kind of highlights you
know uh that they're really not not the
same thing um uh that you you know if
you look at ideology uh with it by you
know race and education it's Sorry by
education and religiosity it's really
quite similar for African-Americans and
for uh and for white people even though
the partisanship is really quite
different and so that's kind of a big
part of the job is kind of moving
between all of these things that seem
similar but actually end up differing in
a lot of very important
circumstances um so when you actually go
and do all this work um you know you end
up with more important election
forecasts which is important for
outcomes um
you know we actually end up uh helping
people you know doing all this work
allows us to help people understand what
policies are popular and which ones
aren't I'm just going to talk about some
parts of this graph because it's funny
so the basic idea here we've pulled
hundreds of different policies so every
single dot is a policy that you know
various people in the Democratic party
have proposed and so the x-axis is is
the support among the overall population
the Y AIS is the support among 18 to 29
year olds uh you know I just want to
pull out uh so basically
the things that are below the line are
things that are disproportionately
unpopular with young people the things
above the line are popular with young
people and so you can see young people
they like student loan forgiveness they
like renewable energy uh but then I
think the funny one it's labeled China
technology is actually Banning Tik Tok
young people don't want to do that which
I think is funny um uh
but uh it also helps us know you know
what to uh tell the Press so you know
here we have uh a histogram of all of
the different talking points uh that
people tested we have several thousand
in our library it's available for free
for anyone in the Democratic party who
wants it and you know what you could see
is that you know the best talking points
really do a lot better than the worst
talking points and so it is actually
important you know to rank these things
and try to say more of the good things
and not the bad things and just to close
up uh just about you know some of the
big picture challenges um you know I I
think the biggest thing about uh in
terms of how I think about my job is
that politics is just a lot more
decentralized than it used to be and I
think you know there are some aspects of
this that are obvious um but others that
I think are only clear if you're a
practitioner uh you know if you go back
to the 2012 campaign you know there
really it used it used to really be that
like there was like David aarod and
David aarod had a deputy named David
seus who was brilliant and he just kind
of the two of them and together were
just like all right this is what the
campaign is going to be and you know
they came up with these like five like
uh five proof points that were on the
wall and it was really creepy like you
once you saw the proof points and you
put on TV you just heard them everywhere
you know was because they they went and
they were able to kind of control the
media environment um you know now
because the basically uh the Democratic
party was the Obama campaign uh due to a
variety of Social and Regulatory changes
one fun one is you know citizens united
made it so that you can kind of uh
donate infinite amounts to these like uh
non-party groups uh that's led to this
really giant transfer of staff and power
away from these centralized campaigns
toward now this decentralized network of
literally thousands of different groups
uh which uh don't talk to each other and
in many cases are not legally allowed to
talk to each other uh and also don't
like each other um as you may have heard
about on the news and so how do you get
all of those different people to speak
with one coherent message um uh that's a
hard problem um but I think that I'm
hopeful that uh you know technology can
help and then I think you know the other
thing and this is something that's
probably clear to people's lived
experiences is just that we used to live
in a world where most people got their
news from the Nightly News maybe some
people watch CNN um I guess people still
read newspapers but there weren't really
that many of them uh now we live in a
world where people really legitimately
spent get large amounts of their news
from things like Tik Tok uh you know the
White House now has to has to care about
individual Tik Tok influencers uh in a
in a way that just uh wasn't true before
and so there's just mechanically the
problem of if you have tens of thousands
of people producing content that people
are going to see how do you measure that
content how do you uh create an
accountability structure to keep to push
people toward making better content how
do you respond to stuff it's all very
hard so all right that's the talk thanks
for listening to all this
and